สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
20023 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 4
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 6
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 10 โมง
10 โมงกี่นาที
5 นาทีค่ะ
ค่ะ 10 โมง 5 นาที
ก็เป็นตอนสายๆนะคะก็ 10 โมงแล้วไม่ถ้าวัน
นี้อ่า 10 โมงตอนนี้นะคะวันนี้แล้วกัน
เนาะวันนี้วันเสาร์เนี่ยกรุงเทพฯ
มีแสงแดด
เมื่อวานนะวันศุกร์เนี่ยนะคะเมื่อวานที่
เป็นวันศุกร์เนี่ยกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีเมฆมี
ก้อนเมฆเยอะมากๆแล้วก็ฝนตกนะคะที่
กรุงเทพฯ
เมื่อวานนะกรุงเทพฯฝนตกหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้า
ตั้งแต่วันนี้
ไม่หนาวนะร้อน
ร้อนเหมือนเดิม
ฝนตกแดดออกไม่ว่าจะเป็นฝนตกใช่ไหมคะหรือ
ว่าแดดออกก็ร้อนเหมือนกันแต่คิดว่าที่
ออสเตรเลีย
น่าจะไม่มีฝนตก
ว่าคิดว่าน่าจะฝนตกตอน
6 โมงเช้าหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าครูพาได้ยิน
นะ
[เพลง]
นอนอยู่นะคะที่เตียงแล้วก็ได้ยิน
ได้ยินเสียงฝนหรอคะ
ได้ยินฝนตกใช่ไหมได้ยินเสียงฝนตกนะ
ฝนตกกี่โมง
6 โมง
ฝนตก 6 โมง
แล้วครูฟ้าต้องตื่นแล้วไปโรงเรียนนี่น่า
จะไม่โอเคนะ
ทำไม
หรือว่าถ้าครูฟ้า
เพื่อนเพื่อนผู้ชาย
เพื่อนผู้หญิงสมัยนี้ครูฟ้า
ทั้งหมดเนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนกันถ้าเราคิดวัน
นี้วันนี้วันเสาร์
ไม่ต้องไม่ต้องไปออฟฟิศไม่ต้องไปทำงานจะ
เจอกันใช่ไหมคะ
ถ้าวันเสาร์ตื่นมาแล้วฝนตก
ไม่สนุกนะเวลาไปเจอเพื่อนแล้วฝนตกนะคะแต่
ว่าโชคอีกวันนี้เนี่ยฝนไม่ตก
มีแสงแดดใช่ไหมคะมีแสงแดด
ก็ถ้าเราเนี่ยคิด
นัดเจอเพื่อนใช่ไหมไปเจอกับเพื่อนอาจจะไป
กินข้าวหรือว่าขับรถเนี่ยมีรถ
มีรถแล้วก็ขับรถไปทะเลสมัยไปเที่ยวทะเล
ด้วยกัน
พวกก็โอเคนะในวันที่แสงแดดใช่ไหมคะวันที่
แสงแดดวันที่มีแสงแดด
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยคนที่มีเพื่อนเยอะมากๆ
มีเพื่อนเยอะนะคะครูฟ้ามีเพื่อน
100 คนอันนั้นเพื่อนที่ Facebook หรอคะ
เพื่อนเยอะไง
ครูฟ้ากับเพื่อนเยอะเนี่ยครูฟ้ามีเพื่อน
10 คนก็เยอะแล้วนะไม่ต้องถึง 100 คนก็
ได้มีเพื่อน 10 คน
ให้ค่ะเพื่อนครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็ไปเที่ยวด้วย
กันใช่ไหม
ไปเที่ยว
วันนี้นะคะวันนี้
หรอ
ได้วันเสาร์
ที่ 5
เนี่ย
วันนี้นะคะ
เพื่อนครูฟ้าไปเที่ยวด้วยกันขับรถไป
เที่ยวแล้ว
จะไปเที่ยวกับเพื่อนครูฟ้าต้องนั่ง
เครื่องบินนะคะจากออสเตรเลียแล้วก็ไปถ่าย
ก็ไม่ทันแต่ถ้าเมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อน
ตอนที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่ที่
ออสเตรเลียอยู่ที่ประเทศไทยเวลาครูฟ้าจะ
ไปเที่ยวกับเพื่อนเนี่ยเพราะว่าอันนี้ครู
ฟ้าก็อยู่บ้านครูฟ้าใช่ไหมเพื่อนครูฟ้า
ทุกคนเนี่ยก็มีบ้างบ้านไม่ได้อยู่บ้าน
หลังเดียวกันเวลาคิด
แปลนใช่ไหมคะจะไปเที่ยวด้วยกันเนี่ยก็
ต้องคิดว่าเอ๊ะแล้วเราจะเจอกันเนี่ยกี่
โมงก็ต้องนัดเวลาใช่ไหมเวลาเนี่ยกี่โมง
แล้วก็ต้องคิดว่าจะเจอกันที่ไหนทุกคน
เนี่ยจากบ้านมาแล้วก็มาอยู่ที่นี่ใช่ไหม
อีก็เจอกันที่นี่ดี c  b  e ครูหญิง
สมมุตินะคะครูฟ้าต้องนัดเจอกัน 1 ที่แล้ว
ก็ไปด้วยกันอาจจะแค่ไปกินข้าวก็ได้นะปกติ
แล้วเวลาที่ครูฟ้าไปเที่ยวกับเพื่อนครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยจะนัดเจอเพื่อนที่ไหนคะ
ครูฟ้า
นัดเจอเพื่อนที่ที่ห้างไหม
บางคนเนี่ยก็บอกว่าโอเควันนี้เนี่ยจะไป
กินข้าว
เจอกันที่ห้าง
สยามพารากอนเซ็นทรัล
11:00 น
ทุกคนก็มาที่นี่
เจอกัน
เจอกันที่ห้างเพราะว่าห้างที่ประเทศไทย
เนี่ยมีทุกอย่างถ้าจะนัดกินข้าวใช่ไหมคะ
ครูสมมุติอันนี้เป็นเพื่อนครูฟ้าทั้งหมด
ใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าชอบกินซูชิอีฮ่างก็มี
เพื่อนครูฟ้าคนนี้ชอบกินพิซซ่าที่ห้างก็
มี
วันนี้ชอบกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่ห้างก็มีบางคน
เนี่ยก็จะนัดเจอเพื่อนที่ห้างไงก็เลยปกติ
เป็นครูฟ้าครูฟ้าจะนัดเจอเพื่อนที่ไหน
ส่วนใหญ่
เจอเพื่อนหลายๆที่นะคะแต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ชอบนัดเจอเพื่อนที่
ไหนคะ
ถนน
อันนี้ไม่ใช่ถนน
ตอนแรกผู้หญิงคิดว่าเป็นถนนเวลาที่เราขับ
รถ
นักเรียนรู้ไหมคืออะไรอันนี้คือรถไฟใช่
ไหมรถไฟฟ้า
รถไฟฟ้า
ครูฟ้าก็จะนัดเจอเพื่อนที่สถานีรถไฟฟ้า
ใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าก็จะเจอเพื่อนที่รถไฟฟ้า
บนรถไฟฟ้าเลยหรอ
สถานีรถไฟฟ้าค่ะ
ตอนนี้ฉันอยู่ที่มันจะมีโบกี้ใช่ไหมล่ะ
ใช่ไหมรถไฟฟ้าแต่มันจะมีโบกี้ที่ 1 โบกี้
ที่ 2 โบกี้ที่ 3 โบกี้ที่ 4 ทางคนก็บอก
เพื่อนว่าโอเคฉันเนี่ยยืนอยู่
โบกี้ที่ 3
นัดเจอเพื่อนที่สถานีรถไฟฟ้าผู้หญิงก็มี
อยู่ใน List นะครูฟ้า
อันนี้เป็นสถานีรถไฟใช่ไหมคะแต่ที่
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยจะมีสถานีรถไฟฟ้านี่ไง
สถานีสยาม
BTS เนาะอันนี้ข้างบนนี้ก็จะเป็นข้างบน
นี้มีรถไฟฟ้าครูฟ้าก็จะยืนอยู่ที่นี่ใช่
ไหมรอเพื่อน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยปกตินัดเจอเพื่อนที่สถานีสยาม
ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
สยาม
ฟ้าเนี่ยเพราะว่าสยามมันเป็น
สยามมีห้างใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนคนก็จะมา
ช็อปปิ้งช้อปปิ้งที่ห้าง
แล้วก็สยามเนี่ยใหญ่
คนไทยเนี่ยคนไทยคนไทยคนไทยคนไทยชอบไปสยาม
ใช่ค่ะ
เพราะว่าตรงนี้มีห้างใช่ไหมเนี่ยฝั่งนี้
เดินเข้าไปเป็นห้างแต่ถ้าอีกฝั่งนึงตรง
นี้ก็มีร้านอาหารมีช็อปปิ้งใช่ไหมคะบางที
ฝั่งนี้เป็นห้างก็คนไทยเด็กๆตั้งแต่แบบ
สมมุติเจอเพื่อนสักอายุ 13 แล้วกันเนาะ
เราจะไปเที่ยวกับเพื่อนเนี่ยจนถึงอายุ 60
ก็ไปเดินห้างโอเคหรือว่าเด็กๆวัยรุ่นอายุ
13 ถึงอายุ 18 ปีก็ไปสยามอีกฝั่งหนึ่ง
สยามร้อนนะคนไทยเรียกฝั่งนี้ว่าสยามร้อน
เราจะเป็นเด็กๆวัยรุ่นแล้วใช่นะเพราะว่า
ถ้าครูหญิงจะนัดเจอเพื่อนก็จะคิดเจอกัน
ที่สถานีรถไฟฟ้า BTS นะคนไทย
เราเรียกว่า BTS นะคะรถไฟฟ้าเนี่ยส่วน
ใหญ่ก็จะเจอสยามก่อนเพราะว่าสยามเนี่ย
สถานีสยามเป็นเซ็นเตอร์ใช่ไหมไปที่ไหนก็
ได้
ใช่ค่ะสยามมันง่ายทุกคนมาสยามมาสยามแล้ว
ก็ไปไปไป
หลายๆที่ง่าย
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าบ้านครูฟ้าบ้านเพื่อนอาจจะ
อยู่กันคนละที่
ง่ายๆสำหรับทุกคนก็คือมาสยามเจอกันแล้วก็
คิดจะไปที่ไหน
นั่งรถไฟฟ้าหรือว่าไปเดินเดินในสยามก็ได้
เนาะมีอะไรร้านอาหารมีให้ช้อปปิ้งมีทุก
อย่างนะคะก็
ครูฟ้าก็นัดเจอเพื่อนที่สถานีรถไฟฟ้าใช่
ไหมส่วนใหญ่เลยใช่ค่ะสถานีรถไฟฟ้า
ก็ส่วนใหญ่ก็สถานีรถไฟฟ้าห้าง
เพราะว่ามันที่นี่คือสถานีรถไฟฟ้าใช่ไหม
นักเรียนเนี่ยสถานีรถไฟฟ้าห้างก็ตรงนี้ไง
สถานีรถไฟ
ก็เดินมารอเพื่อนที่สถานีรถไฟฟ้า
เพื่อนไม่มาครูฟ้าก็เดินไปที่ห้าง
แล้ว
นะคะที่ห้าง
แล้วเพื่อนมาครูฟ้าก็อิ่มแล้วสิคะ
always มันเป็นแบบนี้ทุกทีนะคะเว้าไปกิน
ๆๆเพื่อนก็มา
ฟ้าอิ่มว่ากิน
เฟรนฟรายส์แล้วมันก็อิ่ม
เพราะว่าปกติสมมุติว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนัดเจอ
เพื่อน 11 โมงใช่ไหม
ครูฟ้าก็มาถึง 11 โมงแต่เพื่อนครูฟ้าอาจ
จะมาเที่ยงอย่างนี้หรอ
ใช่เพื่อนมาถ้าครูฟ้ายืนรอใช่ไหมเนี่ย
ถ้ายืนรออยู่แบบนี้ 1 ชั่วโมงร้อนเนาะก็
เดินเข้าไปในห้างคือยังดีนะคะเพราะว่าบาง
คนเนี่ยไม่ได้นัดเจอเพื่อนที่สถานีรถไฟ
ฟ้าปกติเนี่ยสถานีรถไฟฟ้าเนี่ยมันจะใกล้
กับห้างถ้าร้อนก็เดินเข้าไปในห้างแล้วก็
บอกเพื่อนว่าฮัลโหลตอนนี้ไม่ได้อยู่สถานี
รถไฟฟ้าแล้วนะอยู่ในห้างคือเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยตอนครูหญิงเป็นวัยรุ่นนะคะผู้หญิง
อายุแบบ 16
17 อย่างเงี้ยเป็นวัยรุ่นผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ไม่ได้นัดเจอเพื่อนที่สถานีรถไฟฟ้าครูฟ้า
สถานีรถไฟฟ้านะภูฟ้า
แล้วผู้หญิงนัดเจอเพื่อนที่ไหนคะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยนัดเจอเพื่อนที่ป้ายรถเมล์
ตอนครูหญิงเป็นวัยรุ่นเนี่ยก็ประมาณ
20003 อย่างนี้ค่ะนักเรียนกรุงเทพฯเนี่ย
มีรถไฟฟ้าแล้วนะแต่สำหรับเราตอนนั้นคุณ
หญิงยังเรียนหนังสือไงยังเรียนหนังสือใช่
ไหมเวลาจะนัดเจอเพื่อนก็จะนัดเจอกันที่
ใต้รถเมล์ก็จะเป็นป้ายรถเมล์หน้าโรงเรียน
อันนี้จะเป็นโรงเรียน
อันนี้เป็นโรงเรียนของเรา
โรงเรียนนะคะเด็กๆเด็กๆไปเรียน
อันนี้มีถนนใช่ไหมข้างหน้าโรงเรียนเนี่ย
ก็จะมีป้ายรถเมล์ส่วนใหญ่นะหน้าโรงเรียน
จะมีป้ายรถเมล์เพราะว่าเด็กๆก็ลงรถเมล์
ตรงนี้แล้วก็เดินเข้าโรงเรียนซึ่งเมื่อ
ก่อนเวลาครูหญิงจะนัดเจอเพื่อนก็จะนัดเจอ
ที่ป้ายรถเมล์ครูหญิงก็เหมือนกับครูฟ้ารอ
เพื่อนเนี่ย
30 นาที
บางทีนัดเจอกัน 10 โมง
10 โมงเพื่อนก็ยังไม่มาเพื่อนเนี่ยมาถึง
10 โมงครึ่ง
เลยเหรอ
ใช่
นะคะนักเรียนป้ายรถเมล์เนี่ยเราก็นั่ง
นั่งรอเพื่อนที่ป้ายรถเมล์
ร้อนร้อนนะคะ
แล้วก็มีรถมีใช่ไหมไม่ใช่มีแค่รถเมล์เนาะ
มีรถเนี่ยมันวาดยากนะคะ
มีรถใช่ไหมนักเรียนรถเนี่ยก็มีควัน
ยืนรอเพื่อนที่ป้ายรถเมล์เมื่อก่อนนะ
ร้อนแล้วก็เหม็นแต่คิดว่าตอนนี้
2,023
ครูหญิงก็ไม่ไม่นัดเจอเพื่อนที่ป้ายรถ
เมล์แล้วนะไม่นัดเจอแล้วโตแล้วเนาะทำงาน
แล้วรถไฟฟ้าเหอะ
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าห้างก็โอเคมาเขาก็ห้างเนี่ย
มีแอร์นะคะเย็น
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าถ้าอย่างครูวันนี้ใช่ไหม
อย่างเพื่อนครูฟ้าจะไปเที่ยวถ้าเราไม่ได้
ไปเที่ยวห้างเราอาจจะไป
หัวหินไปบางแสนไปพัทยาเพื่อนๆทุกคนเนี่ย
ขับรถขับรถไปใช่ไหมคะถ้าเราขับรถไปเนี่ย
บางครั้งเราก็จะนัดเจอเพื่อนที่ปั๊มน้ำ
มันเพราะว่าทุกคนบางทีแบบบ้านครูฟ้าอ่ะ
อยู่ที่เหนือบ้านครูหญิงอยู่ที่ใต้
อันนี้พัทยาใช่ไหมพัทยาบางแสนเนี่ยอยู่
ทิศตะวันออกทุกคนครูหญิงก็จะขับรถมาอัน
นี้ก็จะขับรถมาบางทีก็ขับรถแล้วก็มาเจอ
กันที่ปั๊มน้ำมันหรือว่าถ้าไม่ขับรถเราก็
ไม่เจอกันเราก็ไม่นัดเจอเพื่อนที่ปั๊มน้ำ
มันเนาะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ามัน
นักเรียนไปปั๊มน้ำมันนิดต้องเดินๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆ
เยอะๆนะ
ว่า
แต่ปั๊มน้ำมันบางทีก็มี BTS ปั๊มน้ำมัน
มันก็มีแหละ
ที่ปั๊มน้ำมัน 1 ครั้งนะคะ
คิดว่าคุณพ่อขับรถส่งครูฟ้าที่ปั๊มน้ำมัน
หรือเปล่า
ไม่ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเพื่อนครูฟ้าเนี่ยมา
ปั๊มน้ำมันใช่ไหมเพื่อนนะคะ
เพื่อนครูฟ้านะคะ
เพราะว่ามีเพื่อนครูฟ้าเนี่ยเขาจะมา
รู้ไหม
อาบน้ำหรอคะ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ปั๊มน้ำมันเนี่ยร้านตัดผม
ร้านสระผม
มาทำผมนี่ปั๊มน้ำมันว่าก็ต้อง
เรียกแกร๊บ
เรียก Uber
แล้วก็มอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่ไหม Uber ก็ขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์มาส่งครูฟ้าที่ปั๊มน้ำมัน
ทำผมอยู่
ต้องนั่ง Grab มาหาเพื่อนที่ปั๊มน้ำมันพอ
เพื่อนทำผมเสร็จก็นั่ง Grab ไปสยามต่อ
แล้วไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะว่านักเรียนนะคะ
เวลานักเรียนเนี่ยนัดเจอเพื่อนนักเรียน
เนี่ยจะนัดเจอเพื่อนที่ไหนก็คอมเมนต์บอก
เราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
เดี๋ยวครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนเจอกันใหม่
วีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
ดีค่ะ